[Music]
once an ivory tower now the city has
become the stuff of nightmares
new prisoners are locked up and tortured
in the prison of hope then they're told
to seek redemption up above
there is none
instead gargoyles carry them to the
upper city where they will inevitably
join the rest of the bodies dumped into
a sea of flesh and blood
tentacles absorb this repulsive mix of
remains
feeding a gargantuan ball of flesh
this heart of latria spits out chimeric
abominations each with the face of a
former prisoner contorted in agony
behind it all is the golden elder a
former noble
consequences be damned he will have his
revenge
in demon souls magic benefits from one's
intelligence the more clearly you are
able to comprehend something the more
powerful your magic becomes latria
clearly had a focus on science and
experimentation you can look to the
equipment in their towers and even the
pictures on their archstone for proof of
that it set them apart from others known
to have practiced the soul arts at this
time like the monumentals who practiced
through faith that's not to say that
latria didn't have a culture of worship
as well they absolutely did look at
what's depicted above the queen's throne
a woman representing royal authority her
body emanating light while a pegasus
glides through the heavens all symbols
of divine and spiritual freedom the
queen was the holiest of holies a being
of supreme magical and therefore divine
power the bridge between man and god
perhaps latria was looking to cross that
bridge the researchers and sages of the
ivory tower elevated themselves to
aristocrat believing that they deserved
to enjoy the finer things as well for
who better to stand beside the queen
than men of similar knowledge i was once
the wife of nobility and i have some
nice things to show for it
to be clear these were not royals they
were nobles
not family but clan
thus since they weren't born into power
it was possible to obtain it
one way was to strive to be intelligent
like the queen
but another was to simply become
wealthier though when your currency is
souls that can quickly become a dark
desire indeed these silver bracelets we
find in latrio they boost the amount of
souls you receive and they're an example
of how the rich get richer it was this
exact same lust for power that triggered
the first scourge
but it wasn't latria that triggered that
instead it was the monumentals luckily
the old one was sealed away by those
same monumentals and the world learns to
fear the power that they had toyed with
and even though it was the bedrock of
their society latria joined the world in
forbidding such knowledge the ivory
towers magical studies were over and
without something to strive for they
must have been bereft of direction
all they would have had at this point
was their queen
and a backstabbing aristocracy
during this age latria would have become
a dangerous place indeed assassination
is clearly a part of their political
culture as the weapons that facilitate
this kind of thing can be found all
throughout this city nobles also
famously took to wearing the red lotus
partly for its beauty but mostly because
it's a quick cure for poison even absent
magic man's malice would have remained
far better suited to this post-magic
world would have been boletaria whose
raw military strength allowed them to
expand their borders evidence of their
spies can even be found within latria
suggesting that the ivory tower might
have been next on their list luckily for
latria the soul was rediscovered by
boletaria who then flourished thanks to
its arts and in order to tip the scales
back in their favor the queen made the
decision to restore her ivory tower
restart research which for so long had
collected dust
latria would once again become a beacon
of academia and this time there was a
wise man named frake who led the way a
former priest freak systemized the soul
arts into an academic framework for
anyone to learn he became known as the
sage of yormoda which was a
distinguished school in latria where the
rich and privileged from all over came
to learn the soul arts including you if
you chose a noble background frake would
go on to travel spreading his methods
and the fame of the yormodar school far
and wide now in this new world where
magic was allowed latria had power and
influence we even have evidence of them
gifting an ornate weapon and shield to a
certain prince of boletaria when he came
touring in its borders they were finally
safe from external forces like boletaria
but turns out it was those at home that
they should have been more concerned
about
among the noble researchers there was an
elderly man who went too far his
obsession with souls crossed the line
and he likely even dabbled in human
experimentation extracting vast amounts
of souls from others
you'll recall it was this exact same
thirst for power that awoke the old one
he owns ago
so seeing these acts as depraved the
queen banished this high-ranking member
of the ivory tower from latria it was
the right thing to do but it couldn't
have backfired more horribly
for she filled him with a need for
vengeance
[Music]
and around this time during his exile
the old one was awoken which triggered
the second scourge demons returned to
the land and it must have been as if
like magic a golden cloth emerged from
the fog and presented itself to the old
man a demon with the power to make the
elderly man's dreams of vengeance a
reality the queen banished that depraved
old man from the land
he returned in strange golden garb with
foul demons in tow
they pillaged great latter land of the
learned
and shot us away in this prison
garbed in that regal color the old man
ravaged latria killed its queen and
imprisoned all who are a part of her
ruling clan to help enforce his new rule
broken servants channel rudimentary
spells throughout the city sustaining
this horrific system of sacrifice
they are protected by former noblemen
who forsook their pride and patriotism
to join the winning side magicians who
transformed into the octopus-headed
jailers still carrying expensive spices
and wearing their old robes since then
they've been feeding off our souls
telling us over and over that if we go
above
we will be granted redemption
the queen is alive they say right there
in the church up above go up and see for
yourself she is immortal rising over and
over again those who survive the cruel
torture and traps
arrive to praise their undying goddess
never noticing the servant pulling the
strings off to the side
to a hopeless soul-starved latrian it
must sound all too tempting she is the
fool's idol after all then come the
gargoyles the souls of latrium soldiers
and knights that became a part of the
local statues they drag worshipers of
this fool's idol up to the horror behind
the holy veneer the old man is making
the prisoners take part in his perverse
experiments creating demons and
fulfilling his role as an archdemon of
the old one no one can stop his revenge
not even freak himself who returns to
latria only to be locked up in a cell
like the rest i was defeated and
captured by the golden usurper past that
cell
be wary of him for he manipulates souls
he has power
over vile murky souls
those susceptible to madness and
paranoia
the elder may be powerful yet the golden
cloth he wears is still a demon its
power is not his own and his soul hardly
matches its appetite the cloth
continually seeks a new vessel to
control and will abandon the old man to
die once it has found that more worthy
body for
the goal of demon kind is not to elevate
humanity to their status
it's to wipe them out and obscure
everything in fog that's the cost of
power here and for some it's a worthy
price to pay
why you have defeated all the demons
have you not
this ghastly howl
the monumental has spoken of it before
there is a question i have long had in
my mind
it is whether we are right to banish the
old one
but i now have the answer
and it is a resounding
no
listen closely the old one must not be
cut off from us
if the candle maiden tries to entrap it
kill her
then
absorb the souls of the old one for
the old one is an unfathomable vessel
it contains all the souls collected by
all demons
you will gain the power of a king
and i will gain knowledge from beyond
and that
my dear friend
is the righteous path
you must not allow trifling matters to
dissuade you
the demon soul is ripe for the taking
before i go i just want to give a quick
shout out to audible and talk about an
audio book that i really enjoyed and
actually got me into using their service
in the first place years ago
so a lot of you probably watched this
video on an iphone and if you'd like to
learn about the man who created the
first one then i can highly recommend
steve jobs an exclusive biography by
walter isaacson on audible have a listen
to this sample and if you'd like to
listen to the full thing for free during
your free trial then go and visit
audible.com vaatividia or text
vaatividia to 500-500 and start your
free trial today
when jobs arrived in the atari lobby
wearing sandals and demanding a job
alcorn was the one who was summoned
i was told we've got a hippie kid in the
lobby he says he's not going to leave
until we hire him should we call the
cops or let him in
i said bring him on in
jobs thus became one of the first 50
employees at atari working as a
technician for five dollars an hour
in retrospect it was weird to hire a
dropout from reed alcorn recalled but i
saw something in him he was very
intelligent enthusiastic excited about
tech
alcorn assigned him to work with a
straight-laced engineer named don lang
the next day lang complained
this guy's a goddamn hippie with b.o
why did you do this to me so i'm sure
you've read or heard about steve jobs
online at least and one of the things
that always struck me whenever i read
about the guy is the comments about him
are either completely full of intense
praise for him and his accomplishments
or their dismissive of the man or
calling him a terrible person for how he
treated other people and after listening
to this audiobook i can say that both of
those comments are kind of true but
neither are the full picture this
audiobook gives a really balanced
perspective into a fascinating person
with some interesting flaws and
interesting character traits that really
allowed him to change the world and some
quotes from this audiobook have actually
stuck with me for years afterwards
remember your membership also includes
access to the plus catalog which grants
unlimited access to thousands of select
originals audiobooks and podcasts no
matter what you're into they've got it
so again go and visit audible.com
or text vati video to 500 500 to get
started today and thank you again to
audible for sponsoring this video